trust me never in my life that I ever
think that I would see Ray Liotta and
Danny Trejo doing a musical dance and
song number together this was a new
experience for me
Muppets Most Wanted is a sequel to The
Muppets film that came out in 2011
starring Jason Segel and Amy Adams a lot
of people really liked that film myself
included I thought that it was just a
total love letter to the Muppets Jason
Segel did a really good job writing the
script and he really had a lot of love
and care for the old Muppets show and it
just shined completely through that
movie a lot of people enjoyed it and it
also initiated a lot of younger people
into the Muppets that weren't initially
into it and it got a whole new thing
started now we have Muppets most wanted
starring Ricky Gervais and Tina Fey and
a lot of celebrities and various cameos
in this film basically this guy named
Constantine who looks exactly like
Kermit except for one mole who likes to
imitate dr. evil a lot he decides to
frame Kermit the Frog by infiltrating
into the Muppets he slaps a fake mole on
Kermit everyone thinks Kermit's
Constantine he gets sent to jail and
this guy Constantine and Ricky Gervais
are trying to find a way to manipulate
the Muppets so they can use the Muppets
show to go to various landmarks all
around the world to rob things of value
and along the way we get a lot of songs
we get a lot of dancing and we get a lot
of comedy unfortunately though it's not
anywhere near as musically entertaining
or as funny as that first Muppets film
or really any of the other Muppets films
this is not a bad movie I did not go to
this movie and say wow I just completely
wasted time I really love the Muppets I
grew up watching the Muppets I love the
Muppets show in fact I have very vivid
memories sitting down with my family and
watching it and I really enjoyed the
other Muppet movies as well one of my
biggest problems I have with this movie
is that there's actually just too much
human interaction in this movie there
isn't enough moppets I wanted more of
the Muppets because that's what we come
to see it's fun to see some celebrity
cameos from time to time but in this
movie it's not very clever like they
have Christoph Waltz in the film and I'm
like wow that's one of my favorite
actors what does he do he does a waltz
with another Muppet they have uh sure in
the movie playing an usher at a wedding
you know it's that kind of thing and it
just doesn't work a lot of it feels very
forced as if a lot of celebrities were
just there because
they like the Muppets and now they're
gonna be in this movie the other problem
I have with it is that it's just not
really that funny and that is the
biggest crime for this movie Jason Segel
had nothing to do with this script he
didn't write it and so for that reason I
think a lot of that passion is missing
even though it's the same director from
the last Muppets movie he does a good
job with this film the way it looks some
of the musical numbers are very well
done the stuff that is with the Muppets
is really fun but unfortunately since
Kermit is separated from the Muppets for
basically the entire movie a lot of that
chemistry is gone and missing in Gonzo's
barely in the movie at all and Walter
from the last film gets the most screen
time out of any of the Muppets but
unfortunately one of the best parts in
this movie is the very first opening
number in which they say the lines we
all know the sequels never as good which
is true and they actually kind of shot
themselves in the foot with that line
because it continues to be proven
throughout this movie Ty Burrell and
Tina Fey were just doing really
exaggerated versions of their accents
and it just kind of felt like this big
we know we're in the giant spoof kind of
thing where a lot of the best Muppets
stuff actually took things semi
seriously
but they had people going like this with
puppets and that's one of the reasons it
was so entertaining because certain
Muppet movies did have those more
serious moments but in this film it just
kind of feels like a big spoof and there
was a lot of really bad CGI actually
which was one of the biggest things that
surprised me they used a lot of CGI for
some of the Muppet moments instead of
actual animatronics and puppetry and
that's one of the things that made the
original Muppets so cool to watch was he
knew that somebody actually was like
working this type of magic with puppets
and this film a lot of it is like
Constantine fighting and kicking people
and it's CGI and it doesn't really look
very convincing I am gonna give him up
it's the most wanted a C+ though because
as I said I was entertained enough as I
watched it because I loved the Muppets
and there were some funny parts to it
and it wasn't a boring movie it just
wasn't really as funny as it could have
been and a lot of the celebrity stuff
felt very forced and there wasn't enough
Muppets in the Muppets oh and by the way
there is a criminal under use of the
Swedish Chef in this movies in like two
scenes I love the Swedish side he's my
favorite where was he so guys if you
have seen the film I'm interested in
knowing what you think of it let
know below when you see the movie guys
thanks so much for watching and as
always if you liked this you can click
right here and get stuck Munoz